police say early indications show an
uber self-driving SUV may not have had
time to stop or avoid hitting a
pedestrian who was killed in Arizona
uber suspended all testing of its
autonomous vehicles after the Sunday
night crash Kris Van Cleave is near the
crash scene in Tempe Arizona Chris good
morning good morning that uber had
multiple cameras on board so police are
gonna have a good view of this crash
they say the woman started in this
median and when abruptly into the road
and may not have given that vehicle
enough time to be able to stop now one
of the questions for the National
Transportation Safety Board once they
get here it should have all that
technology on board that self-driving
car been able to sense that the woman
was coming Tempe Arizona police say uber
SUV was operating in autonomous mode
with a human backup driver when it
struck and killed 49 year-old Elaine
Herzberg initial indications are the
uber was traveling northbound at just
under 40 miles per hour around 10:00
p.m. Sunday night when Herzberg
attempted to walk her bicycle across the
road from west to east she was at least
60 yards from the crosswalk when she was
struck and killed our investigation did
not show at this time that there were
significant signs of the vehicle slowing
down
friends say Herzberg had struggled with
homelessness and she was trying to get
her life back and was succeeding with it
uber in a statement said our hearts go
out to the victim's family were fully
cooperating with local authorities today
we have hundreds of self-driving
vehicles out in the world
uber has been testing the technology in
the US and Canada for months no one was
injured in its only other accident in
Tempe last year when one of its
autonomous SUVs was hit by another
driver the company is just one of
several racing to be the first to
develop fully driverless cars it's
difficult to say right now what this
means about the safety of these vehicles
Tim Stevens covers the autonomous
vehicle industry for CNET's Roadshow
dealing with the unpredictable nature of
humans is definitely the biggest
challenge that these autonomous
researchers have to face it's too early
to tell whether or not the technology
actually could have prevented this crash
Tempe Police Sergeant Ronald Alcock says
their investigation is just beginning do
you investigate a self-driving car
accident
then when to human driven cars collide
sure with the self-driving vehicles
there's going to be a little bit more
in-depth investigation as to what kind
of technology may have been on that
vehicle and what technology was working
at the time of the accident and again
early indications here neither the
safety driver nor the woman who was
struck were showing any signs of
impairment
bianna Chris thank you